welcome back to my Harry Potter series
I'm so excited to be talking about these
movies leading up to fantastic beasts
and where to find them later this year
I've already reviewed Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone had a great time
talking about that movie with you guys
and now we're moving on to Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets once again
directed by Chris Columbus his last film
that he provided in the franchise and
again scored by the amazing John
Williams with his great Harry Potter
theme if you saw my review for the
Sorcerer's Stone you know that I really
enjoyed that film it's by no means my
favorite Harry Potter film but it did a
good job of setting up that universe
Chamber of Secrets benefits from not
having to set up this universe in
chamber of secrets we already know about
Hogwarts we already know about all the
principal characters we already know
about Harry's horrible Guardians who are
the worst Guardians you could imagine
these people are so terrible and that
really helped you care about Harry
Potter and so even though this film is
pretty long it still moves a little bit
faster than the first Sorcerer's Stone
did because you're instantly into the
story a lot earlier this film set up a
very compelling mystery what is the
Chamber of Secrets kids at Hogwarts are
being petrified frozen stiff cryptic
messages written in blood are found on
the walls and Chamber of Secrets for me
benefits by being just a bit darker than
Sorcerer's Stone and presenting a more
compelling mystery this film also gave
us the introduction to the character of
Dobby who at first is very annoying and
you're kind of like oh crap this could
be bad gratefully he's not in the movie
that much and he does become a more
interesting character towards the end of
the film and one that you can kind of
side with when you see what's actually
going on behind the scenes with Draco's
father who's even worse than Draco oh my
god what a garbage human being and when
you see Dobby as that manservant you
realize why is just this little broken
creature and you kind of want to comfort
him and you also realize why Draco is
such a jerk because his father is ten
times worse I just got to say though
when I rewatched this movie yesterday
seeing Ginny just reacts to Harry Potter
being there
um mommy have you seen my jumper lizard
was on my cat huh what did I do
Jenny she's been talking about your
summer that's one of the cutest things
I've ever seen in a movie that was just
adorable she's crushing on Harry Potter
hardcore and all of a sudden he's in her
house I was just like ah young love
blossoming before my eyes so along with
that mystery involving the Chamber of
Secrets you also learn a little bit more
about Harry Potter he can speak in
Parseltongue he can talk snake so not
only is Potter famous for being the boy
who lived but now he can talk to snakes
and it sets up more compelling things to
make us curious about this character
just why are these things happening to
him what is the Chamber of Secrets and
that's one of the things I like more
about this movie in the first one
there's more of a mystery element to it
there's more of an exploration element
and I love seeing our three heroes
teaming up to learn more about this one
of the downfalls with this movie is a
similar one that I have with home alone
- to home alone all these movies are
directed by Chris Columbus but home
alone - was kind of a retread of home
alone and Chamber of Secrets also has a
very similar feel to the first
Sorcerer's Stone I think it was a wise
choice the next Harry Potter was done by
a different director because these first
two are almost interchangeable which is
OK and I can give it a pass because it's
a franchise but there are a lot of
elements that feel like haven't I seen
this already one of my favorite parts of
this movie is when Kenneth Branagh and
Alan Rickman have a battle these two
different characters have a quick little
magic battle but even better is directly
after that when Harry and Draco have won
- which is cool because you hate Draco
and just want to see this kid just so it
was tons of fun to see these two
characters face-off and as I said this
movie is a bit darker and slightly more
scary than the first one especially the
scene with the spiders why is there a
spider scene why are there so many
spiders there's a big spider there's
little spiders there's too many spiders
in this movie oh I thought Lord of the
Rings Return of the King was bad there's
so many spiders something else this
movie improved over the first was the
Quidditch special effects the Quidditch
sequence in this move
is a lot more fun for me than the first
one because it just looks better it's
like they learned they were able to
create a better sequence after doing it
the first time it's a lot more fun to
see Harry catch the snitch in this movie
because it just looks better this film
is a more focused movie it does have a
better idea of its story because it
doesn't have to take so much time to set
up all these characters and once we get
to the big finale in which Harry finds
out that Tom Riddle is not exactly a
very good person as well as his epic
face off with the basilisk and there's
some really good CGI work for 2002 as
well as a great practical creature here
again a very cool fantasy family movie
that just makes you want this universe
to be real but it's not real fake but I
just gotta say towards the end these
last few scenes these three kids are
just so great together they bring a
giant smile to your face I can't talk
enough about this casting I loved the
interplay between these characters I
loved seeing them grow and mature and
that is a rare thing in films to have
this many films in which you can watch
these characters quite literally grow up
in front of you and they pulled it off
from me chamber of secrets is just ever
so slightly better than Sorcerer's Stone
but I am going to give it the same grade
of a B+ guys thank you so much for
continuing to watch my Harry Potter
series of reviews I can't wait to talk
about the Prisoner of Azkaban because
that for me is where this series gets
awesome you guys are the best thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
you